what they're doing here that they're
just making it's terrorism they're
terrorized and burnt my friends got guns
on their front porch or by the front
door because they're not scared of the
cops they're scared of the militia
coming to our abilities from Arizona
they're from Nevada it's not their land
nobody's headed up right in here it's
time for them to go ahead and go on home
now they got their their shot at Fame
they got on the news coverage I've
scared our kids we've shut our schools
down
I support the idea that the Hammonds
have cut and dished out a grave
injustice I don't support armed militia
when shopping the day's safeway and we
have sheriff protections in the stores
all this is has greatly affected the
community
it needs to be happening long time ago
but as long as there's no disk you know
anybody doesn't get hurt the economy
having the good sense the 80s because
the mills went down and there was no job
too for anybody except for government
and law enforcement